-♫ Face It, Face It, Face It
Challenge ♫
-Now, here´s how it works.
Each round, we will draw a card,
which will tell us what face we
both have to make.
We´ll look in our mirrors,
make our faces
and then reveal them
on the count of three.
We´ll stare at each other
for 10 seconds
while trying to hold our faces.
First person to crack a smile,
laugh or break the face loses.
Let´s see what our --
-[ Laughs ]
[ Both laugh ]
-Stop. Stop. Here we go.
Let´s see what the fir--
Don´t say anything.
-Oh, no.
-Here we go. Let´s see
what our first face is.
The first face is...
trying not to vomit.
-Right.
-Okay. Trying not to vomit.
Okay, uh, we´ll take a moment
to make our faces.
-[ Gags ]
-Are you ready?
-All right, I´m gonna vomit
so I can --
-Three, two...
-Oh, well, wait a minute.
What -- What?
-Three, two, one.
Trying not to vomit.
[ Laughter ]
-When do you reveal?
-One. Oh, sorry, yeah.
Ready?
-Yeah.
-One, two, three.
[ Laughs ]
[ Buzzer ]
-That´s insane.
-Oh! Oh!
-I think I´ve actually burst
a blood vessel!
-Did you do somethign?
-I´ve pulled a muscle.
I pulled my muscle!
-You did it on that?
-Oh, God!
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, my God. Just doing that?
-I´ll go see a doctor,
"And how´d you do it?"
I´ll go, "Well, I did this."
[ Gagging ]
Like that.
Oh, right.
-Ricky, you go and choose
the next one.
I´m sorry I laughed at that.
-Okay. Okay.
-I got to make sure, that´s how
you do a trying not to vomit.
-All right.
-All right, here we go.
-Oh, this is --
Oh, this is mine.
Double chin? Come on.
-I could do that. I can do it.
-Easy.
-Yeah. Here we go. All right,
ready?
Three.
Two.
One.
[ Both laugh ]
[ Buzzer ]
-Right. Right.
Right.
What I did, right, this is my
downfall, all right?
So, I was sort of offside,
and it was blurred,
but then I saw a focus, and all
I could see was the chin.
So, I lost.
-All right, it´s a tie game.
Oh, let´s take a moment.
Here we go.
-Okay.
-Ooh. Creepy smile.
-Creepy smile. Here we go.
-Creepy smile?
-Creepy smile.
-Okay.
-Three...
[ Laughter ]
Three...
[ Laughter intensifies ]
-I think it is right.
I´m doing it to myself
in the mirror.
-I know, I know, I know.
-It turns me on a little bit.
[ Laughter ]
-Creepy smile.
-Count down then.
-Three, two, one.
[ Laughs ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
-One more. One more!
-No, no. You pulled it away
funny.
You pulled it away funny, too.
I forgot that´s also a thing
you can do.
All right, the last one´s
up to you.
You can read this one, yeah.
- [ Giggles ]
Getting caught in the zipper.
Does that mean this zipper?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Yes.
-Well, that´s never happened.
Just one of the advantages
of having a very small penis.
-[ Laughs ]
That´s not something you brag
about!
No, you don´t brag about that.
-I hate to boast, but it´s
pretty tiny.
-Oh, my God. That´s not --
You don´t brag about that.
All right, getting caught
in a zipper.
[ Laughter ]
Three, two, one.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Buzzer ]
-Ricky Gervais, everybody.
He´s the champ.
-Ahh.